si vous cherchez un smartphone extra
résistant et bien il y a le Honor Magic
6 L qui est vraiment intéressant et
surtout à un prix mini un smartphone
tellement résistant qu'on peut venir
planter des clous
avec voyez il y a même pas une
égratinure la technologie h Nord ultra
bounce anti drop ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que si votre smartphone il
peut être amené à tomber on va pas
planter des clous avec c'est pour la
démo ne le faites pas chez vous bien
évidemment et bien vous êtes sûr qu'il
est quand même certifié résistant ça
veut pas dire que une mauvaise chute
garantisse à 100 % qu'il va pas se
casser attention vous amusez pas à le
reproduire et à le jeter chez vous
certes il est certifié par SGS étant
extrêmement résistant il a la note 5
étoiles mais il se peut que
malencontreusement en faisant aussi une
mauvaise chute l'écran puisse s'abîmer
donc attention vous amusez pas à le
jeter ce que ça certifie en tout cas
c'est que vous êtes tranquille il est
résistant et ça c'est une très bonne
chose d'un point de vue technologique il
a une technique d'amortissement qui a
été créé par odor ici avec des matériaux
spéciaux qui ont été choisis pour vous
assurer ici un écran résistant ce qui
vient augmenter sa capacité d'absorption
au chute fois 1,2 ce qui globalement est
vraiment bien ça lui permet donc d'avoir
une meilleure durabilité avec des chutes
d'une hauteur de 1 m 50 et ça sur tous
les angles de l'écran et pour tout ce
qui est visionnage de film de série vous
avez un écran de qualité c'est un écran
de 6,78 pouces qui est très grand donc
aucun problème pour venir vous amuser
même pour le gaming ça ira bien et
surtout la technologie ici AMOLED 1
milliard de couleurs un écran avec un
tau de rafraîchissement qui va jusqu'à
120 Hz ça en terme de fluidité c'est
vachement bien lorsque vous allez venir
naviguer et pour le gaming tau de
rafraîchissement vous le laissez en
dynamique comme ça vous êtes bien vous
êtes tranquille ça va vraiment bien et
surtout cette année par rapport à
l'année dernière par rapport au Magic 5
Lite le Honor Magic 6 l passe d'une
résolution de 1080p à une résolution de
1,5 K et le soir lorsque vous venez vous
coucher et bien il y a aussi vachement
de techno qui vont venir prendre soin de
vos yeux sur votre écran vous venez
juste dans vos paramètres paramètres
vous allez sur Affichage et luminosité
et là vous allez avir plein de choses
pour venir prendre soin de vos yeux déjà
c'est un écran qui va venir lutter
contre la lumière bleue qui va donc
éviter la fatigue oculaire ça c'est le
premier bon point et ça on aime vous
venez dans affichage confort des yeux et
dans confort des yeux et sommeil et là
vous avez plein de choses super la
première chose c'est l'affichage
nocturne circadien en fait c'est quoi
c'est votre cycle de sommeil il vous
l'écrivent ajuste automatiquement la
température de couleur de l'écran en
fonction de votre rythme corporel pour
vous aider à préparer une meilleure nu
de sommeil bien évidemment lorsque cette
option est activée la couleur de l'écran
devient plus chaude donc on casse un peu
le côté lumière bleue et on vient
réchauffer l'écran ça il faut le faire
c'est extrêmement important autre truc
qui est vraiment important c'est le
confort des yeux moi ce que je vous
conseille quand même c'est de venir
l'activer en permanence vous le mettez
pas trop fort vous le mettez un petit
peu ça vient également jaunir un peu
l'écran et après il y a plein de
technologie c'est vraiment un truc que
j'aime énormément chez Honor et vous
avez déjà la gradation dynamique qui
vient ajuster intelligemment la
luminosité de l'écran afin de réduire
l'effort demandé aux yeux et d'améliorer
la santé de vos yeux donc une fois de
plus ils viennent prendre soin de vos
yeux et c'est une techno qui est très
importante et puis il y a une autre
techno très importante dont on a déjà
parlé chez Honor c'est la gradation PWM
1920 Hz en fait qu'est-ce qui se passe
c'est de l'antisatiment c'est un truc
qui est totalement imperceptible pour
vos yeux si bien que lorsque vous
regardez votre smartphone et que vous
venez baisser la luminosité le soir dans
votre chambre comme ça tranquille à la
maison vous allez pas avoir ce côté des
sentiments qui va venir réellement
fatiguer vos yeux ça vient réduire
totalement une fois de plus le sentiment
vous avez également le mode ebook si
vous aimez lire sur votre smartphone et
bien vous venez l'activer une fois de
plus ça vair réduire la fatigue oculaire
vous passez en noir et blanc pour vous
retrouver comme si vous étiez sur une
bonne liseuse are point qui a été
amélioré c'est la taille de la batterie
on est passer d'une batterie de 5100
mahh à une batterie de 5300 mahh alors
vous me direz 200 mahh c'est pas fou
certes mais c'est déjà ça et ce qui est
bien ici c'est que l'autonomie est
certifiée duré 2 jours 2 jours en usage
mixte pas en usage intensif attention
mais deux jours pendant lesquels vous
allez être tranquille sans devoir
forcément venir recharger votre
smartphone c'est bien qu'il a obtenu le
bxo Mark batterie gold ce qui fait donc
du Honor Magic 6 Lite un smartphone sur
lequel on peut venir compter en terme
d'autonomie et en plus de ça Honor nique
vous allez garder 80 % de la capacité de
votre batterie pendant 3 ans minimum ça
c'est quand même aussi une super
nouvelle entre mise à jour qui est
intéressante sur ce smartphone c'est le
capteur photo principal qui est passé
d'un capteur de 64 mégapixel sur le
Honor Magic 5 Lite l'année dernière à un
capteur de 108 mégapixel sur le Honor
Magic 6 Lite la taille du capteur me
direz-vous ça fait pas tout cert mais
par contre ça vous permet quand même
d'avoir plus de netteté plus de
précision et surtout de venir zoomer
numériquement dans la photo pour avoir
l'équivalent d'un zoom optique x 3 alors
je vous montre on se fait quelques
photos allez on se fait quelques petites
photos ici à Vegas une photo de mon coco
qui cadre à contrejour des photos du
Treasure Island au fond du venigian du
Palazio ici et là vous avez vos photos
pouvez venir zoomer dessus sans perdre
de détail c'est tout l'intérêt d'avoir
un gros capteur de 108 mgapixel ça sera
vraiment bien pour venir zoomer une fois
de plus je dis dans l'image et puis il y
a un autre truc qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est en pH Nuer grâce à
technologie du pixel binding regrouperé
plusieurs pixels en un seul et même gros
pixel ce qui vous permettra d'avoir des
photos meilleures en faible luminosité
de vous à moi le Honor Magic 6 Lite mais
pour autant pas un photophone pour ça il
faut commencer par la série numbers chez
Honor avec pour l'instant en tout cas le
Honor 90 ou encore mieux le Honor Magic
5 Pro mais déjà ce que vous propose ici
le Honor Magic 6 Lite est extrêmement
convainquant et pour vos photos du
quotidien ça ira très bien tout en
sachant en plus que vous avez un
deuxième capteur c'est un ultra grand
angle de 5 mégapixel et un capteur macro
de 2 mégapixel avec une distance de 4 cm
bon ok ça fait le T côté performance on
trouve un snap dragon 6 Gen 1 à
l'intérieur qui est un processeur qui
est gravé en 4 nanom qui conviendra bien
attention on peut venir jouer à des jeux
pour regarder ses films ces séries ça va
bien le smartphone est fluide peux venir
naviguer dedans sans aucun problème vous
voyez c'est réactif ça souvre ça se
ferme directement de tous les côtés j'ai
aucun problème donc ça c'est vrai que
c'est quand même un point qui est
vraiment très très fort ce qui est bien
i c'est que vous avez 8 Go de RAM mais
en plus de ça grâce à la technologie de
RAM turbo de horf on monte jusqu'à 16 Go
de RAM avec votre RAM physique et votre
RAM virtuelle et en plus de ça 256 Go de
stockage donc si vous me posez pas de
question vous pouvez mettre des films
des séries de la musique des jeux des
tonnes d'applications vous ne manquerez
pas de stockage et ça sur le smartphone
c'est extrêmement important à ne pas
prendre des stockages trop petits autant
vous dire qu'ici avec 256 Go de stockage
vous avez de quoi faire autre avantage
de ce smartphone c'est son design sa
finesse sa légèreté il fait à peine 185
g et le fait d'avoir un smartphone très
fin comme ça personnellement j'aime
beaucoup il est bien la prise en main
est top vous le prenez à une seule main
vous faites le tour ça c'est cool aussi
le Honor Magic 6 L est disponible dans
trois coloris vous vous avez la couleur
verte que j'ai ici il y a aussi le
classique noir et il y a le Sunrise
orange qui a une exclusivité sur le site
ionor bien évidemment je vous mets tous
les liens juste en bas dans la
description Le Honor Magic sisla é en
préommande à partir du 10 janvier 2024
il est disponible au tarif de
399,90 en plus de ça Honor vous offre
des Honor X5 sont des écouteurs d'une
valeur de 59,90 € et vous avez en plus
de ça un coupon de 100 €. profitez-en
rapidement c'est à durée limitée je vous
mets bien évidemment un lien juste en
bas dans la description pour venir
acheter votre Honor Magic 6 Lite dans
les meilleures conditions le Honor Magic
6 Lite est un smartphone avec un M écran
endurant résistant qui sera très
polyvalent bref tout ce qui rime avec an
correspond auon Magic 6L et en plus je
vous le dis pendant les précommandes et
même pendant le lancement c'est un
smartphone qui a un tarif extrêmement
intéressant bien évidemment toutes les
conditions sont juste en bas dans la
description vous avez le lien qui vous
emmènera directement sur le site de
Honor pour venir l'acheter une fois de
plus dans les meilleures conditions
pensez donc à venir cliquer sur le lien
juste en bas et puis si vous avez un
budget à moins de 4 100 € avec en plus
le coupon de 100 balles avec en plus les
écouteurs offerts et bien c'est un super
bon plan pour venir acheter un
smartphone extrêmement polyvalent pour
venir jouer à des jeux pour du gaming et
pour plein de choses bref ça c'est
vachement cool et d'ailleurs ici vous
l'avez vu dans le Honor Magic 6 Lite
vous avez énormément de technologie pour
venir prendre soin de vos yeux si y a
beaucoup de soil donc voilà ça ça prend
soin de mes yeux mais on fait tous pas
mal d'erreurs lorsqu'on utilise nos
smartphones je vous invite donc à venir
voir cette vidéo là qui vous montrera
les SEP erreurs qu'on fait tous et
surtout comment venir les corriger pour
faire très attention à nos yeux
lorsqu'on utilise des
écrans